et action bravo m'as tu vu ça va mal ça
c'est un mur d'éclairage bien naïf on
n'est pas la porte par yann auliffe des
pourparlers de motorola mais ce muret
nolifes on va changer dans les faits ce
devoir je crois que si je clique là
pas ça que je veux c'est pas mal ça bon
ok on n'est pas accompagnée de ça on est
là pour parler aujourd'hui de motorola
motorola qui fait son grand retour dans
l'univers des smartphones vous
connaissez probablement motorola si vous
êtes des gens comme moi qui avais sur
des cheveux gris sur les cheveux blancs
ce qui est un peu des anciens ou alors
si vous êtes plus jeunes c'est peut-être
le téléphone des parents motorola c'est
un smartphone facettes des téléphones
plus que des smartphones en tout cas
historiquement qu'on a connus au début
des années 2000 c'est notamment un
smartphone avec l'apix motorola c'est un
petit peu fait oublier n'a pas forcément
réussi à prendre en tout cas ici en
france le virage des smartphones on en a
déjà parlé quelques temps je vais tester
notre smartphone de motorola mais bon
c'est vrai que sur le devant de la scène
la marque était quand même une très
grande inconnue hors jeu d'éclairage de
l'oranje c'est sympa lorsque la petite
histoire dit pas c'est que motorola il
marqua continue à performer continua
marché notamment aux états unis où ils
ont pas moins de 5% de parts de marché
tout cas actuellement c'est le quatrième
acteur d'un monde de la téléphonie
mobile est également en amérique du sud
ou motorola est le deuxième acteur avec
15% de parts de marché brésil argentine
mexique
motorola fait partie du même groupe que
les nouveaux donc on les retrouve en
asie au travers de lenovo
lise développe notamment avec une forte
croissance revienne enfin voilà et
motorola fait le choix de revenir il ya
très peu de temps pour travailler
fortement l'europe donc ils ont une
bonne progression en europe de l'est et
en europe du sud et les attaques trois
marchés prioritaires que sont la france
l'allemagne et liu km m soit peu dire
que le uk fait partie de l'europe
c'est une question qui sera intéressante
autres qu'en termes de territoires ddt
qu'en termes de géographie
ils sont par là donc ils font partie de
cette priorité en tout cas aujourd'hui
pour motorola
moi ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est de
savoir comment est ce que cette marque
va faire pour revenir un petit peu
draguer des consommateurs qui les tente
probablement oublié et pas d'autres
smartphones ya plein d'autres marques à
pain d'acteurs alors je suis sûr que
vous aujourd'hui le smartphone que vous
avez ce n'est pas un motorola mais
peut-être qu'à l'avenir vous allez vous
positionner sur votre smartphone de
motorola donc comment est ce qu une
marque qui revient comme ça va réussir à
vous emmener à vous raconter l'histoire
différemment c'est justement ça qui
m'intéresse
frikha mines ça va très bien mènera
welch est au top
toi tu es directrice marketing de
motorola france tout à fait ok laurent
seillier j'étudie un petit peu je te
suis je sais tout sur toi donc j'aurai
qui me racontent en a les deux minutes
max l'histoire de motorola par rapport à
votre arrivée autres car autour sur le
marché ou en 2021 à l'ecoute motorola
c'est une marque assez intéressante
parce qu'elle est emblématique est la
une
forte notoriété mais pas une notoriété
auprès de tout le monde
tout dépend un peu de lâches que tu as
finalement si tu ta à peu près mon âge
ou tournage on connaît bien cette marque
c'est une marque qu'on aime beaucoup
qu'on a beaucoup vu dans les années 90
et les années 2000 etc à un fort capital
sympathie comme on dit un peu dans le
jargon markets
par contre si tu t'adresses à des plus
jeunes à les 15-25 là c'est un petit peu
plus flou c'est souvent le téléphone de
nos parents c'est un clapet on sait pas
trop c'est une marque un peu vintage
donc vraiment la nôtre notre ambition en
tout cas sûr sur cette année ça va être
de redorer le blason de cette belle
marque qui sait faire beaucoup de choses
des téléphones qui sont à la fois fiable
qui sont beaux et qui en plus sont assez
innovant de par leur technologie
donc on va vraiment s'appuyer là dessus
pour redorer le blason de la marque et à
se faire connaître et revenir sur le
marché français comment est-ce qu'on
retarde la zone motorola aujourd'hui en
2021 alors on va faire plein de choses
déjà la redynamiser la rendent de
nouveau visible avec des belles
campagnes avec des collaborations avec
une actualité assez forte finalement sur
2021 pour vraiment émergé dans un je
dirais secteur concurrentiel qui est
assez chargé donc voilà ça on va essayer
de différent d'être singulier et
d'adopter vraiment une tonalité là où on
ne nous attend pas forcément avec des
codes j'irai dans l'air du temps et qui
parle aux plus jeunes et aux un peu
moins jeunes évidemment forcément en
terme de stratégie ils vont devoir
arriver dans ce qu'on appellera le
retail donc le commerce dans des
boutiques physiques mais également dans
des boutiques en ligne pour du
e-commerce
il ya aussi toute la stratégie
opérateurs parce qu'en france on
n'achète quasiment tous nos smartphones
par notre opérateur et puis bien
évidemment tout de la stratégie qu'on
appelle 'b to b' professionnel vous
savez que tam en des groupes comme la
poste à la sncf y compagnie équipent
leurs collaborateurs de smartphones et
là-dessus motorla également présents il
ya donc une gamme qui est complètement
réécrit en tout cas en france pour nous
des bus 2021 et on va tout de suite posé
la question en maths il pour savoir
quels sont ses gammes et comment ça
fonctionne mathilde ça va très bien et
heureux oui très très bien vrai qu'une
parle de la gamme de motorola en 2021
je m'explique un petit peu comment elle
se structure tout à fait donc
1021 c'est vraiment l'année de la
rationalisation de la gamme chez moto
voilà on va retrouver dans quatre
différentes
je te propose de commencer par l'entrée
de gamme ouais c'est le moto les motos e
moto peu lentement j'veux dire que là on
est vraiment sur l'entrée de gamme donc
du produit a plutôt 99 euros aux
alentours de 200 euros vraiment c'est
des produits avec une belle promesse
pour un prix vraiment très accessible
ensuite on va avoir donc les motos j'ai
donc passé vraiment le coeur de la gamme
donc là on va être aux alentours de 150
euros jusqu'à 600 euros
cette gamme n'allait vraiment historique
1 pour motorola
c'est notamment cette année la dixième
génération de moto j'ai voilà donc on
est sur des produits vraiment
performants et accessibles à tous et
aussi petite particularité cette année
aussi on a refondu à le naming pour
qu'ils soient toujours à toul claire et
plus simple pour le consommateur ça veut
dire que si j'ai dix je suis pas cher et
c'est un geste en jeu plusieurs
exactement plus on monte plus on ait un
premier mains ok donc là c'était la
gamme moto j'ai ensuite si on monte on
va retrouver donc les motorola edge donc
là c'est vraiment notre gamme flagship
premier homme donc là on va être aux
alentours de 6 ans jusqu'à 800 euros et
enfin pour finir notre dernière gamme
qui est vraiment notre vitrine
technologique donc fait notre gamme de
pliable ou de clion il ya deux écoles
avec donc les motorola razr fin mars
2000 vingt ans ils viennent tout juste
de présenter de nouveaux modèles qui est
le g50 et le gie sans que ce soit le
j'ai cinquante objets sont les sur des
smartphones 5 g l'idée c'est
effectivement d'être présent auprès des
opérateurs les opérateurs veulent mettre
en avant la saint jean valjean des
abonnements s'agit donc il faut de la 5g
et là on va changer la couleur
voilà le bleu bien oui j'adore objectif
très cool pas d'anciens modèles anciens
razer première génération alain donc qui
était sorti en 2003 2004
ça c'est le modèle il pas celui qu'on
retrouve partout à l'époque et qui a
complètement cartonné c'est ça d'accord
ils sont son évolution c'est le razer 5
des noms qui étaient sortis
l'année dernière avec donc cet écran
pliable et quand tu le recul tu va
également pouvoir retrouver dans toutes
les notifications essentiel à l'avant on
va donc tomber sur ce j'ai 50 avec
hassan ragone à 480 écran de 6 5 pouces
90e 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage
côté photo on va voir une combinaison un
peu classique quand on va voir un grand
temps de 48 mégapixels un capteur
profondeur de 2 mégapixels de la macro
en 5 mégapixels bon ça ça ne convainc
jamais et on verra comment le travail
motorola en tout cas ici une caméra
telle fille de 13 mégapixels et d'une
grosse batterie de 5 millions période et
surtout âgé 50 au tarif de 249 euros
donc plutôt bien positionné et le
deuxième modèle qu'ils ont présentés
c'est le g100 fin du xixe et talent ça
c'était le le packaging du rider
d'origine donc ça c'était le packaging
de l'époque exactement dans l'allier a
notamment à côté tu vas pouvoir
retrouver donc son packaging actuelle
donc deux dirigeants le g100 c'est le
haut de gamme de motos g ya ici à sa
dragonne 870 qui n'est pas le processeur
le plus puissant qualcomm mené presque
le plus puissant c'est le 888 mais avec
le 870 vous aurez vraiment tout ce qu'il
vous faut
en termes de performances donc ça
fonctionnera vous aurez absolument aucun
problème couple est à 8 gigas de ram et
128 go de stockage extensible grâce à
une carte micro sd que vous avez un
écran 6 à 2 7 pouces avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 heures ce ratio
vingt neuvième
côté photo vous allez voir un
grand-angle de 64 mégapixels un ultra
grand temps de cette méga pixels de la
macro 5 mégapixels dont c'est toujours
un peu la même chose à voir bien
évidemment et un capteur de profondeur
de 2 mégapixels métaux qui m'intéressent
là tu sais qu'il ya un truc un peu
différenciant ce sont les deux caméras
de celle-ci vous en avez une de 16
mégapixels et une de 8 mégapixels celle
de 16 mégapixels ça sera votre caméra de
celle fille un peu standard et la 8
mégapixels sera luttera grand-angle
lorsque vous avez plein de potes autour
de vous qu'il fallait rentrer dans le
champ d'un switch et et vous allez les
avoirs par contre ce qui m'intéresse ici
c'est que ils n'ont pas fait le choix de
me sauver cette espèce de grosse bulle
autour on a vraiment ces deux petits
points sont de petites caméras qui sont
posées dans l'écran comme ça bon a vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez bien
évidemment pas en commentaire
vous trouvez ça esthétique ou alors pas
du tout on a une batterie de 5 millions
perreur édition des de la recharge
rapide 20 watts du wifi 6 enfin un
smartphone qui est très cohérent on a un
lecteur d'empreintes digitales sur le
côté sur la tranche une prise jack
on va retrouver avec ce qu'ils appellent
leur ai dit fort alors le ready for
c'est un petit dock un petit dock vous
allez pouvoir brancher sur un moniteur
sur un écran sur une télé
plusieurs usages dans le premier c'est
effectivement le gaming vous le posez là
vous avez une petite manette et vous
jouez vous utiliser la puissance de
votre smartphone pour venir jouer faut
savoir qu'avec le g100 forcément vous
avez de la puissance et un dragon 870
vous pouvez également l'utiliser comme
un petit ordinateur chez vous vous de
poser dans votre dock pareil petit
clavier souris vous bossez vous pouvez
également l'utiliser pour faire la couv
cole lorsque vous travaillez vous
utilisez soit votre caméra de celle ci
soit la caméra derrière pour bien vous
filmez et sur votre grand écran et bien
vous avez tous vos interlocuteurs massa
notamment pour le travail est bien fait
ça vraiment pas mal et bien évidemment
pour le divertissement pour mettre vos
fils en gros sans votre télé ça c'est
très cool et se raidit fort surtout il
est inclus dans la boîte avec votre g
-sand vous achetez votre g sans vous
avez votre dock avec sans débourser un
centime de plus et ça c'est très bien
est ce un smartphone qu'on va y
retrouver entre 500 à 550 euros alors à
laquelle j'ai eu toutes les informations
je n'avais pas le tarif définitif donc
qui va se situer dans cette gamme de
prix est donc vous voyez on est sur un
une gamme qui est très cohérente que je
crois en tout cas assez intéressante à
voir une fois de plus en avoir parce que
pour l'instant je les ai deux je trouve
intéressant j'aime bien l'histoire
viendra conter motorola puis j'aime bien
pour arriver de nouveaux smartphones
j'aime bien voir comment des marques
arrivent à se réinventer cherche à se
réinventer vous raconter une nouvelle
histoire
et si on vraiment dire travailler
l'image en ayant ce qui est ce que les
américains bien appeler côté disruptif
c'est vraiment en ayant une approche
différente
- sur le produit mais plus sur la
culture de la marque et sur la marque
avec ce logo motorola qui a ses acolytes
donc ça on le suivra on regardera ça
prochainement
en tout cas je compte en vous pour dire
dès maintenant ce que vous en pensez qu
est ce que signifie pour vous motorola
est ce que c'est une marque de référence
est ce que c'est une marque qui pourrait
vous intéresser ce qu'a contrario c'est
une marque est passé auquel auquel vous
voyez absolument pas ça c'est pas des
non vraiment ce que vous en pensez mais
curieux de voir vraiment se produisent
les ai vus il va monter par les tester
surtout de voir ce qu'ils vont rendre ce
qu'ils ont dans le ventre
la propos je trouve cool voilà et puis
surtout une fois de plus un acteur
différent comme ça assez intéressant
donc on en reparle très bientôt
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire la marque les produits
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
jean raoux des gros bisous garder des
rockers purge encore lumière pour
dernière fois parce que ce truc là ça me
fait vraiment marrer un juif
voilà je kiffe les limites de rabais
totaux